[Music]
filmmakers tasked with adapting comic
book icons for the big screen have their
work cut out for them
after all redesigning a universe filled
with flashy super suits and living
planets can be a bit of a challenge plus
screwing up the balance of faithful and
creative means inspiring the fiery wrath
of comic-book fanboys and nobody wants
that
luckily the Afro futuristic nation of
Wakanda and its denizens have been given
one badass makeover for the big screen
and even though were super into the
aesthetic that director wine Googlers
bringing to the table let's take a look
at what the cast of Black Panther should
really look like T'Challa
Black Panther the man behind the Black
Panther mask sakala has been the king of
Wakanda since his father's death drawing
the signing of the sokovia accords in
Captain America Civil War like his
Avengers Ally Tony Stark
T'Challa isn't afraid to switch up his
gear every once in a while since going
toe-to-toe with Bucky Barnes also known
as winter soldier in his MCU debut
T'Challa snagged a spiffy new costume a
lighter energy absorbent vibranium suits
this one boasts a more tribal aesthetic
reminiscent of illustrator
Andy parks early concept design of the
butt-kicking king's panther mantle Black
Panthers new suit remains relatively
faithful to recent comic runs and
T'Challa himself looks pretty close to
his comic book counterpart to where
chadwick boseman z' interpretation of
the character isn't afraid to rock the
scruff however his comic book equivalent
is all about keeping that chiseled jaw
fur free still Bozeman's T'Challa is a
near-perfect real-life interpretation of
the king cut in black ulysses klaw wall
black panthers titular hero is more or
less identical to his comic book double
its main antagonist ulysses klaw has
undergone quite an overhaul portrayed by
master of motion capture andy serkis
clora swapped out his comics
counterparts bulky sonic blaster for a
souped up retractable prosthetic but by
far the biggest difference between the
charismatic arms dealer and his sinister
supervillain namesake is the fact that
circuses Klaw is obviously not a being
made entirely of living sound
technically Marvel Comics Klaw was also
once a bearded human jerk but his
eventual redesign is a red and purple
body and frequent nemesis of the
Fantastic Four is the farm
memorable incarnation of the one-armed
heel sure a sister of T'Challa and
smartypants vibranium tinkerer princess
Shuri is a force to be reckoned with
not only is she the greatest scientific
genius this side of stark tower but in
the comics she's taken up the Panther
mantle on a number of occasions in her
brother's absence in other words like
T'Challa she's consumed the heart-shaped
herb and reap the same superhuman powers
Shuri portrayed by Leticia Wright in MC
use black panther has undergone a
dramatic redesign chief among the
differences as an outfit a sleeveless
tunic and a full mantle with neck
coverage along with what appears to be a
chin guard while a comic book Sheree
doesn't wear much makeup say for the
occasional strip of paint over a chin
the emcee used wakandan princess adorns
herself with a series of white dots
across her forehead brow cheeks and chin
she also wears her hair in a braided
updo while her comic book counterpart
typically wears her hair short under an
ornate headdress of a black panther mask
kill manga in the comics the exiled and
shamed Rory and the Jataka adopts a
pseudonym kill manga blaming both to
Charlie's bloodline and claw for his
parents demise in an intriguing twist
Michael B Jordans interpretation of the
character a former American Black Ops
soldier named Erik Stevens teams up with
the South African supervillain Klaw
instead of you know beating him to a
bloody pulp the first chance he gets the
MCU sees kill manga who earned his
nickname on the battlefield transformed
from a Herculean behemoth to a buff
badass with a sense of style the MCU
zarok Stevens may have lost his source
material straight up a murderer aura but
he more than makes up for it with hip
sensibilities combat know-how and his
very own gold Jaguar suits
Lakia if the pizza' Nyong'o has proven
anything since her award-winning
breakout role in 2013 12 years a slave
is that she can do no wrong so casting
her among the black panthers pantheon of
brilliant actors must have seemed like a
no-brainer
Nyong'o portrays Nakia a secret agent
summoned back to a conjurer at the
behest of T'Challa in the Black Panther
comics Nakia teams up with kill manga
and eventually adopts a villain persona
malice after her obsession with the
titular wakandan King lands her in hot
water while the comics counterpart is
known for her be
and hair and jewelry the young goes take
on the character wears her hair in tight
curls and Duns a variety of get ups
including full Dora Malaysia armor in
Baku thankfully the Black Panther comics
problematically named man aid will be
sticking with his birth name mbaku
for his film debut producer Nate's more
however admits that the gorilla gods are
important to embark whose tribe the
Jabari verse while he's ditching the
name Toa Condon throne seeker and
potential unlikely allied to T'Challa
will retain a touch of white fur along
his arms and legs his revamped wardrobe
is a nod to his source materials
gruesome costume a white gorilla hide
that he'd and after killing a mythical
abe skinning it devouring its flesh and
bathing in his blood
yikes ramona matriarch of wakanda wife
of the late to chucker
and a mother of two Charla and Cherie
Ramona has suffered greatly at the hands
of her husband and Sons political rivals
yet despite years of family tragedy
she's proven herself to be a vital asset
to the wakandan High Council in the
Black Panther comics Ramona has been
depicted with both black and white hair
the MC use film on the other hand sees
angela bassett to take on the character
at a most regal rocking ivory dreadlocks
and the Wardrobe fit for the queen
mother of Wakanda Zuri in the Black
Panther comics Zuri was a personal
attendant at a chucker before the out of
rulers death he would go on to serve the
same role for a son the young King
T'Challa
that is until the Warriors and timely
demise at the hands of Marlon an energy
vampire in a sequence of events that's
way too complicated to talk about here
suffice to say Suri plays a slightly
different role in the MCU a spiritual
obi-wan type the wakandans shaman like
figure is something of an advisor to
T'Challa and his kin appearance-wise
these two interpretations look like
entirely different characters while the
Marvel Comics iteration of Zuri is a
hulking behemoth complete with bursting
abs and the neck thick of the most men's
waists Forest Whitaker isn't that's not
to say the acting veteran doesn't look
rad in his own right
trading as comic doppelgangers black
mane for a bolt dome and adding a splash
of color to his drop robes Zuri's big
screen interpretation calls to mind a
wise outer figure
Everett Ruess let's face it Martin
Freeman doesn't exactly stand out in a
crowd under neither just Black Panther
comics ever at Kay Russ he's without
question the least interesting and least
super-powered guy in the mix but
personality-wise the cold no-nonsense
CIA operative we met in Captain America
Civil War is a total 180 from the
Chandler Bing inspired diplomat to task
with escorting T'Challa unto American
soil in the comics in the Black Panther
film Russ finds himself involved in a
conflict between Ulysses Klaw and
T'Challa causing him to team up with
their cons and King and become one of
his most trusted allies while these two
versions of Rasta polar opposites in
terms of attitude personality behavior
and just about everything else the suits
at MCU did a bang-up job nailing his
clean-cut style or at least they did in
Civil War sure that may both be average
looking middle-aged white dudes but the
perpetually suited to sarcastic for his
own good diplomat who once sold his soul
for a pair of pants wouldn't be caught
dead in a t-shirt and casual jacket okay
that's the stretch we know but there's
really not much to say about this guy
could he be any more nondescript
io like Everett Ruess we briefly met ru
in civil war during a confrontation
between two challahs feisty head of
security and Natasha Romanoff aka Black
Widow while we learned a little to
nothing about IOT's character from a
short scene a single line of dialogue
like you will be moved
shine the light two more week had come
to expect from the dollar melash agents
keeping Black Panther safe as a top
priority iOS on-screen presence seems
more or less in line with a comic book
counterpart they've both vowed to
protect their King and loved ones on
many an excursion across Wakanda and
beyond that being said comic book IO has
a bit more possess honor film
doppelganger who keeps things simple
with a shaved head and traditional Dora
Malaysia Alma in the comics IO rocks a
sick sci-fi shaved head ponytail combo
along with glyph like egg down her
forehead and across her cheeks
Okoye yay like io a coy way is a member
of two challahs personal bodyguard unit
the Dora milosh a and while a number of
the fearsome sisterhood soldiers wear
their ink proudly in the comics MCU
Zakai a shaved head and
unique angular tattoos has her standing
out from the squad deny Guerrero's look
is as close as you can get to the comics
portrayal of the royal band of butt
kickers depending on the run that is
black panther comic right certain RC
coats contemporary take on the troop
sees them rocking their infamous facial
tats and hip haircuts but Christopher
priest was the brains behind their comic
book debut and his interpretation of the
bodyguards was more in line with your
typical femme fatales impractical tight
dresses and all
Maccabi Daniel Kalu years Maccabi shares
his comic book counterparts primary
responsibilities as chief of wakandan
border tribe security in the black
panther comics Maccabi would prove to be
an invaluable Ally to T'Challa even
becoming his second-in-command before
dying alongside Zuri at the hands of
Moreland
again that dude whose Ark were not even
getting into like zouri for copies MCU
interpretation differs from his source
materials incarnation so dramatically
that the uninformed might mistake him
for a brand new character while the
Black Panther comics depict Maccabi with
a bundle of wild dreadlocks and little
clothing so as to not restrict him while
he's bashing skulls
Kalu here's character of the same name
it sticks to a relatively reserved look
appearing more like an angry puppy than
the grizzled Bionic armed warrior we've
come to love and mourn thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all his cool stuff we know you
love to
[Music]